hi this is presh talker in this video
i'm going to illustrate three methods
for proving e is an irrational number
the first proof is by contradiction
we'll assume that e is a rational number
then we'll look at the infinite series
for its reciprocal 1 over e
this will lead to a contradiction that
an integer minus an integer will equal a
fraction
and so we can conclude e must be
irrational
let's assume that e is rational that it
can be represented as a over b for two
integers
recall the power series is the sum of x
to the n divided by n factorial
one over e can be found by substituting
negative one
and that'll be the sum and the
alternating sum of the reciprocals of
factorials
now if e is rational
that means one over e is also rational
and will equal b over a
and this is where we're going to show
there's a contradiction
the key thing is grouping
the infinite series for one over e into
the terms going up to a and then all the
terms after a
the thing is no matter what term you
have for a we're going to have a problem
that all those extra terms are going to
be this fraction and that's going to
lead us to this contradiction
so let's imagine subtracting 1 over e
minus all of the terms up to a
what we end up with is b minus a minus
all of the terms up to a and that'll be
equal to all of the terms after a going
from a plus 1 to infinity
let's multiply each term one by one by a
factorial and then we add this negative
one to the a plus one factor this will
just be so that our alternating series
starts positive you'll see why in a
minute but basically think about
multiplying each term by a factorial
when we multiply b over a by a factorial
we end up with b times a minus 1
factorial and then we have the negative
1 to the a my a plus one
the key thing about this term is that
every single term in it is an integer
the negative one term is an integer b is
an integer and a minus one factorial is
also an integer
so this entire term is an integer
we then multiply a factorial
by all of the alternating terms going up
to a
what's important here
is that the denominator is always less
than a factorial
and that means every denominator in this
alternating series is a factor of a
factorial so each of these terms in this
alternating series is an integer
and therefore the alternating sum of
integers is also an integer
so these terms are all integers
so we now have an integer minus an
integer being equal to whatever remains
so now let's multiply whatever remains
by a factorial
when we do that we end up with the first
term as one over a plus one
and then the second term is minus one
over a plus one times a plus two
we then end up with a bunch of other
terms it's an alternating series but
every denominator
will be larger so the next term will be
one over a plus one times a plus two
times a plus three and so on
what's important about this series is
that we can have an upper bound on it
clearly this infinite series
will converge to something that's
smaller than the first term because
we're subtracting things after it
so the upper bound is one over a plus
one and we can also find the lower bound
as the sum of these first two terms
when we do that we'll find out that this
has to be between zero and one
because a has to be greater than one we
know that one over e cannot equal to
something divided by one
and this is where we get the
contradiction we have an integer minus
an integer equaling something between
zero and one
this is not possible
so there's no way we can represent one
over e
or even e
as a rational number because we're going
to end up with this contradiction
therefore e must be irrational
a second proof by jonathan sondell is a
geometric interpretation
we're going to construct e from line
segments
will then show that e will always be
between fractions of n factorial
will show that every rational number
would equal a fraction of some n
factorial and since e cannot equal a
fraction with the denominator n
factorial this means e is irrational
we'll construct e from line segments
we'll go ahead with the infinite series
the first two terms are one plus one
so we have a line segment which starts
at two
we then want to add one over two
factorial to it
we can do this by considering a line
segment of length one
line segment going from two to three
and then we need to add one half
so we'll divide this into two pieces
and in order to add one over two
factorial we'll just keep the second
piece
so this second piece this is getting us
closer to e
now we want to add one over three
factorial
so three factorial is found from
dividing one over half into third
so we need to divide this one half into
three pieces
we go one two
and in order to add 1 over 3 factorial
we again keep the second piece
so we know that e is somewhere in the
second line segment
to add 1 over four factorial we divide
further into four pieces one two three
four
and once again we keep the second piece
so e will be somewhere in between the
two endpoints of this fourth
interval
we can continue this process
iteratively by dividing the next piece
into next line segment into n pieces
and then keeping only the second piece
as we get all of these intervals
we can then say that e will be the
intersection of all of these intervals
we're getting closer and closer and the
intersection of everything will be equal
to e
now how does this help us
if you look at the end points for each
line segment
that's going to be the key insight
the first interval goes from 2 to 3
the second interval goes from 5 over 2
factorial to 6 over 2 factorial the
third interval goes from 16 over 3
factorial to 17 over 3 factorial
you can write an explicit form for each
interval
and it turns out that for n greater than
1 each subsequent interval is always
between the endpoints of the previous
one and it always has a very specific
form it's always going to be between two
numbers a and a plus one with the
denominator n factorial
so if you look at the second interval
it's between five and six for two
factorial if you look at the third
interval it's between 16 and 17
and that's the key insight
no matter what denominator n factorial
we have
every single interval
will be just a difference of a and a
plus one
and we know that e is somewhere in
between it so e is never going to be a
fraction for any denominator n factorial
so why is this important this is going
to lead us to our contradiction
we know that e is not a fraction with
any denominator n factorial
however
any number that is rational will always
equal some fraction
of
n factorial
how is this well consider we have a
rational number p over q
if we multiply the numerator and
denominator by q minus one factorial we
have
the rational fraction p times q minus 1
factorial over q factorial so every
rational number can be expressed
as a fraction with some denominator
q factorial or n factorial
so since e can never be represented as a
fraction with any denominator n
factorial
we can conclude e is irrational
there's a third proof i want to mention
that comes from euler i'm just going to
sketch the proof out
the steps are to show that e has a
continued fraction representation that's
infinite
the second observation is that rational
numbers always have a finite continued
fraction representation
and that'll imply that e has to be
irrational
so e has the following continued
fraction representation it's equal to
two plus one over the quantity one plus
one over the quantity two plus one over
the quantity one plus one over the
quantity one plus one over the quantity
four plus so on
we can write this continued fraction
representation in a simpler way it's
always going we always have one over
something so we just look at the other
parts the other numbers two one two one
1 and 4.
these are the only pieces we really
numbers we really need to know in this
continued fraction representation
because everything else is redundant
it turns out that e has the continued
fraction representation that starts with
two one two
then it goes one one four one one six
one one eight one one ten and so on
every third number in this increases by
two
this was proved by euler
i provided a link of this proof in the
video description
there are some interesting functions
that you have to go through and show
that there's a convergence
but you can prove that e has this
continued fraction representation and
it's infinite because every third number
keeps increasing by two
on the other hand rational numbers
always have a finite continued fraction
representation
this is due to the euclidean division
algorithm so i'll give you an example
let's say we wanted to convert the
number eight over three into a continued
fraction
we know that eight over three is at
least two
we end up with two and two thirds
so in order to get a continued fraction
representation we need this two-thirds
to be one over something
so how do we get one over something
well let's consider the reciprocal three
over two
if we divide three by two we get one
plus one half
so we can also write two thirds as one
over three halves which is then
one over one plus one half
and now we have a continued fraction
representation of eight thirds which is
two one and two
and this terminates in a finite number
of steps and for any rational number
this will always terminate in a finite
number of steps due to the euclidean
division algorithm
so since finite
since rational numbers always have a
finite continued fraction
and e has an infinite continued fraction
we can conclude therefore e is an
irrational number
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can also catch me on social
media at preshtalwalker and please check
out my books i've written several books
about math and game theory
there's link in the video description
thanks for watching